what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Fantastic
Fest 2023 sitting next to making Flair
hello two for two with feature films as
a director I am mighty impressed today
we get to celebrate Toxic Avenger thank
you very much you opened fantastic
Festival oh man that's what we were
hoping for we we mentioned this after
the show last night but we really
um when we were talking about where we
would love to Premiere this movie
everybody's first and only answer was
fantastic Fest it's like grown in a lab
to host this kind of a movie and uh the
folks seem to dig it so we couldn't be
happier now that I'm first feeling The
Vibes of this Festival myself I can
understand why that was the thinking
yeah I want to go back to the beginning
with this idea so is it a situation
where you knew legendary had acquired
the rights to the original film and you
went to them with an idea it was the
opposite of that they I I had um I had
done a little bit of work for them
um elsewhere and they brought it to me
they had just gotten the rights this
makes me respect legendary way more than
I already did well they did they didn't
offer it to me on a platter they said
what would your take be as I'm sure they
did to a bunch of people and I I told
them what I thought and I really
Scout's Honor expected them at any point
to say no like thank you for your time
but that's not what we're into I I kind
of half assumed that maybe they would
want a PG-13 or or something that's more
family friendly or or mainstream however
you quantify that and I kept saying like
it's got to be R it's got to be a dude
in a suit It's gotta be like silly and
ridiculous and like purposefully
Juvenile and they kept going yeah yeah
yeah yeah and at a certain point it was
like okay well I'm just gonna write this
goddamn thing and uh and we'll see what
happens and here we are oh I have so
many follow-up questions about many
things you just said but first I know
you're a big trauma fan but why direct a
Toxic Avenger movie for your second
feature as a director honing his craft
what did you think you would get from
this material that would benefit you as
a director moving forward I love that
question and here's it's sort of like
when I was a young person I saw the
movie and it
um at a very impressionable age and it
got stuck in my head and kind of formed
what I liked about movies in some ways
as I got older I started watching other
things and so it's not like I carried
around this idea that I needed to remake
the Toxic Avenger I didn't have that
idea at all until legendary brought it
up but
I had tried to do several movies that it
it wasn't necessarily the story as much
as a list of ingredients which was
um a big silly
comedy that's also rated R that also has
monsters that's also kind of sentimental
and warm-hearted
um and so I would have these uh uh
things that I would write they would be
exorbitantly expensive rated R worst of
all not based on an IP they were never
going to get made and they didn't some
of them I reworked as comic books but it
was just like I could never do that type
of movie and then all of a sudden
legendary was like we've got this IP
um and it's the Toxic Avenger and I was
like well if ever there was a a
um an already existing character or prop
franchise whatever you want to say
um that demanded it be big and goopy and
silly and sentimental and sweet and
gross and all those things I was trying
to do it was this one and I was like oh
this is how
um I could scratch that itch and make
that type of movie with the support of a
studio like legendary that has the
resources to make a movie like that and
also like was into the type of again the
type of movie that I was hoping to do
which is
um
uh you know it's for the Fantastic best
crowd exactly that that leads me into
another big burning question I had
because trauma has a significant fan
base as does Toxic Avenger it's a very
specific fan base though that if that's
not your type of movie it's difficult to
welcome more people into that fan club
so maybe what's something about the 84
original that you knew you wanted to
uphold for the longtime fans but then
what is something you deliberately
strove to do different to broaden the
fan base yeah and that was absolutely
the kind of tightrope like how do we
honor the fan base because we we knew we
had to make something that would appeal
to them and they would feel like yes you
didn't like take this thing that's
beloved to us and and take it in some
new direction that it it doesn't warrant
um but as you said there's also it's a
very devoted vocal fan base but of the
overall movie-going population it's
quite a small sliver so he had to make
sure they were taken care of first also
make sure that people that had never
heard of the Toxic Avenger were also
going to be taken care of and so for me
it was like certainly the
silly on purpose kind of juvenile on
purpose sense of humor anything for a
laugh anything to sort of like tickle
people sensibility
um that you know revolves around
physical gags and gross makeup and stuff
like that we definitely wanted to
preserve all of that excuse me
um but with this one in the original the
main character he was a teenage guy and
he was kind of an outcast at high school
and it was really about him trying to
get accepted by like the cool kids and
the pretty girls and him having he was
like an outcast nerd and we kind of felt
like
they had already done that it it really
would be too much of stepping exactly in
the same footsteps to have that be the
dynamic again and so for this time the
character is older he's trying to raise
a um a stepson he's trying to raise a
kid on his own and it's just having a
hard time with that he's not really cut
out to be a dad and he's not really
connected to this kid and so that's the
kind of emotional story that we bury
within all the mutant Mayhem stuff
that's going on so that was sort of the
new thing the new direction we tried to
take it in I am about to jump into how
damn good Peter Dinklage is in that role
of playing that character but first just
to compare 84 trauma to what you do now
I'm also curious to apply a similar type
of thinking to just the visual style and
the filmmaking techniques that you use
what was the key I guess to being able
to uphold that you know that low budget
80s cult classic kind of feel but while
also incorporating modern filmmaking
techniques and uh and tools so that
Modern Art audiences feel it's fresh and
real there was a thing where uh the
Director of Photography was named Dana
Gonzalez
um and he's just a brilliant dude and we
talked a lot about how we were going to
kind of artificially restrain ourselves
where even if we wanted to have big
swooping camera moves digitally assisted
movements and all this kind of stuff we
we really kind of tried to limit camera
movement and make it seem as if
um we were like handcuffing one of our
hands to to have it have this feel that
it's it's a little more Indie and
self-contained we broke that rule
sometimes there's some some I can think
of some really cool shots
exactly where we go kind of big but it
was just you know we kept the coverage
very basic we kept the framings very
basic so it would have this kind of feel
of a movie that had to be shot in 16
days and you have to get this shot and
then the police are going to come and
you don't have a permit and you've got
to hit the road that kind of a of a run
and Gun sort of vibe charm of trauma
movies yeah exactly which is like I mean
being able to see those little
imperfections certainly having toxic be
an actor in a suit as opposed to their
you know they're I guess there could be
a world where tops see would be an Andy
Circus CGI you know 20 foot tall
something or other but that was one of
the first things I said I was like it's
really got to be rated R and it's got to
be an actor in a suit and those were the
things that they agreed with and so
having that physical tactile uh quality
to it where you can see the little
Bubbles and lines and stuff like that
that's part of the texture that I think
people who
um know this character would would hope
to see many questions about that
incredible suit first what would you say
is the biggest difference between draft
one of that design that you saw and what
toxy looks like in the finished feature
you know what um he started out way more
what would be a way to say it um
more like a zombie more like rotted off
and and much more monstrous and so we
went through a series of you know just
when we were in the art phase and and we
had a couple of really great artists uh
one was named uh Vanessa Menendez and
one was named Jonas mccluggage
um he's a comic book artist she's a
painter and and we I was really
exploring some real
um Night of the Living Dead type looks
and then we kind of took a second look
at that and and we kind of as it went
further along we tried to humanize them
a bit more
um and and so that even though he's got
all these boils and I'm not sure if
people have seen the movie when they
watch this or not but it's no spoiler
that he looks gross
um he's got boils and warts and blisters
he's got one super uh distended eye
um but within that you can still see a
lot of humanity and so we kind of we
pushed the monster side of things really
far and then walked that back I don't
know how much you could speak to this
because their team is a little more
Hands-On with how all of this works but
what kind of conversations did you have
in terms of making sure that like the
design and Peter in it was able to be so
expressive because it looks like a very
heavy prosthetic to me but when I'm
watching the film like I can I can see
things as small as eyebrow movements and
that makes all the difference in a
performance like that it's the eyes for
sure exactly and that's why like
um an actor in a suit like if if we
could spend a year animating some
something maybe you could get that type
of like reactive detail but there's
something about just like like as you
said an eyelid doing this at a pivotal
moment of dialogue that is you know it
costs nothing but it's the best effect
in the movie because it's like oh you
can feel his his beating heart inside
there so yes we definitely worked with
the um uh with the suit designers and
and the makeup artists to make sure that
that sort of
um performance would come through that
was that was something that seemed
really important was that when he you
know the first 20 minutes of the movie
he's a human and then he has a crazy
um science fiction accident and he
becomes this mutant monster and really
wanting it to feel like you could see
that human character inside all that
goop and grossness later on and not
treated like okay now he's a monster
we're starting fresh it's a brand new
guy it really had to have that
continuity and the connection that the
audience made with human version once he
turned turned into Monster version great
great success in that respect so going
back to the beginning with Peter now
what was it about him that one day made
you wake up and think he is the perfect
toxy and then what was his first
reaction when you pitched it to him okay
yeah I mean it's it goes back to that 20
minute window at the top of the movie
where it's kind of like we really have
to draw people in to this character and
his plight his the way he's trying to
connect with his kid the way he's kind
of out of sorts in society and has been
dealt a raw deal
um and if they're not sympathizing with
him by then by the time he turns into
the monster then they're not going to
get on board after that point and so
um we we knew that we wanted an actor
who could instantly engender that kind
of sympathy in the audience could also
be very funny both with dialogue and
also physicality and can also be quite
dark and
um full of rage and and kind of check
all these boxes and there's some actors
that can do a little bit of this or a
little bit of that there's there's fewer
still that do all of it simultaneously
and fewer still that can do all of it
simultaneously and are famous enough to
kick start the movie which is also what
we needed and so it was kind of like oh
I was very fortunate that um I had met
Peter at a film festival and we had just
kind of stayed in touch very casually
just kind of like would you read this
script would you read that script um in
the Years leading up to it Film Festival
absolutely he's he saw he saw a movie I
did and he he said hey can I buy you
lunch and we hung out and and this was
right when Game of Thrones was wrapping
up so like a fool he gave me his phone
number and so then every Sunday night I
have a couple of beers and I'm like are
you gonna end up on the iron throne and
he's like
so maybe he regretted that but we stayed
in touch and um I was just like oh he
can do all of that stuff
um and can have that kind of every man
sort of quality that will get people on
board with him before he turns in to the
monster and so I brought it to him and I
I said exactly what I said to you I was
like it's sort of like you know you'll
we'll hear you throughout the movie but
we're really going to be spending time
with you at the beginning and so it's
kind of a heavy lift and it's kind of a
lot of pressure but
I I felt like it was going to be a fun
time for him and like a fun role that
um he hadn't gotten to do a big over the
top I mean he's he's terribly funny but
he tends to play more
um dramatic roles most of the time
um uh lately anyway and um and so I
think this was a chance to to really go
into the funny side of things same thing
with Kevin Bacon he was like oh it's a
villain because he's like he's like
people keep wanting me to play corrupt
cops and stuff and I was like yes he is
the villain but it's super silly it's
super Goofy and he was like okay and
then he read it and then he called back
he was like oh yeah now I get it it's
not like villain villain it's like
lowercase V villains so um I I think
that was attractive to both of them
getting to do something they don't
normally get an opportunity to do to
high lady a bit more of your incredible
Ensemble here of all the characters in
the movie which was the easiest to cast
where like the perfect person kind of
magically came to you but then I want
the exact opposite the role that took
the most leg work to find the perfect
fit for oh wow yeah
um Fritz Elijah Wood playing Fritz who's
like a uh he's like the henchman carries
out the Dirty Deeds for the bad guys and
and he's kind of like this
um
Gothic creep looking guy with you know
he's baldy like the whole idea was to
make him be unrecognizable as like
um sweet kind faced Elijah Wood and just
have him be as equally as monstrous as
as toxic was
um I wrote that part for him and
um and was just like I didn't really
think about anybody else for that one
and and luckily I pitched him to
Legendary I pitched the part to him and
everybody was very quickly on board that
was the easiest it was just kind of like
a perfect to have him in that role and
then to bring this movie to Fantastic
fest with him in it it was just meant to
be I think so too I mean it was just
um one of those he's got like
I don't know if they're doing it this
year but in years past they had a tattoo
artist here and so they were worried
about that you know I will do it if I
see it and I like it he's got like a
whole collection of fantastic uh of
course he does tattoos on his arm from
over the years he's here every year so
yeah it did feel like absolute full
circle
um
um getting him in the movie and then
getting to Premiere it here they have a
taxi tattoo are you gonna get it 100
okay oh Lord I hope so I hope so wait so
now I need the other the other half of
that question the the role that took the
most leg work to find the right fit for
the one that took them you know legwork
makes it sound like it was an impossible
equation to solve and and it wasn't but
the the the part that we really looked
at a lot of different people for was JJ
who was a new character and she's kind
of like
um she's sort of like a rogue
investigator that's gathering
information I'm sort of giving you some
context if people haven't seen it but
she's gathering information to take down
this evil Corporation and she um is
actually she kind of starts the movie as
a hero and kind of sets this example to
toxy who uh you know he doesn't want
anything to do with with fighting
anybody or anything like that she kind
of brings him along that path and and so
it was um a character where we we felt
like we didn't necessarily need somebody
who was a superstar that everybody knew
but we ended up very luckily getting
Taylor Page who at the time when we shot
it was um I had just seen uh Zola and my
rainey's and and she was just fantastic
in those and and I actually sort of
um oh I'd seen my rainies and then I saw
Zola a little bit later in the process
and it was just sort of like wanting
somebody who had that toughness and that
grit but was not
um
it didn't have like an actress thing if
you know what I mean like like she it is
she's very vanity free like she doesn't
need to be like perfect lighting and
like make sure everything she's just
kind of like like rolls with it and is
in it to sort of like scrap and get
physical and and do all the running and
fighting and jumping um and they're all
so it's kind of like this fun action
role that again I don't think she got to
do but she just had this um very
believable realistic quality to it as
opposed to like
um like a a black widow type of
character where everything is so perfect
and precise you know there's there's
kind of like a clunkiness to it which I
find very endearing like she makes
mistakes that she goes to like every
time she tries to make progress against
these bad guys something goes wrong and
so she's always flustered which is very
funny but you you kind of go on that
ride with her and eventually so does
toxic her chemistry with Peter and Jacob
is just so incredibly perfect and that's
what's vital for the heart of the this
movie to make them feel like a little
family that you want to get behind and
very successful precisely so it's it's
sort of like they're all like on
scattered corners of the board and then
like throughout the thing they kind of
end up
on a little bit of an uneasy team
together which is fun to say mind
delivery she's got some just like pitch
Pitch Perfect lines and like perfectly
timed lines where it's just sort of like
not playing it to be funny but it's sort
of like with one step removed from it it
is fun things that I want to read
and down here I can't end this
conversation without talking about your
collaboration with
so yeah what was it like working with
him and how did he support upholding the
trauma Vision but also supporting your
vision for this character as well he we
I mean it's not that he was hands off he
definitely like had notes and
suggestions and but he he always framed
them every single time it's like now
this is your thing like he there was no
like I really hope you'll do this or
that it was it was really just hey if
you want to do this and some of the
ideas end up in the movie and and some
of them didn't just because we were
doing different stuff but he was always
um he came out to visit the set in
Bulgaria and I I think that was a lot of
fun for him because it's
um you know it's shooting in Europe and
it's this weird German germ of an idea
that he had you know 40 odd years ago
and it's become this phenomenon now and
he's kind of looking at these sets and
everything like that and and he said it
was very touching to see it continuing
and enduring after all these years so he
was he was very supportive
um and and always seemed to like want to
overstate that like this is yours I'm
not gonna get in the way I'm not going
to get in the way and at a certain point
I was like you can get in the way a
little bit more than that man like um
but you know uh it was it was important
to me as much as sort of crafting a
story that the trauma fans would love
that Lloyd and also Michael his sort of
behind the scenes partner
um were involved and part of it it would
just be sort of like if if all we did
was take the title and then go do our
own thing without bringing the original
Squad along for the ride that would sort
of defeat its own purpose too yeah so
um you know I just kind of look at it
like you know you've got Batman and then
there's Adam West Christian Bale Georgia
there's all the Batman's got James Bond
you got all the different James bonds
and you can discuss which ones you like
better or worse or whatever I kind of
feel like toxic is the same type of
character that can withstand and
actually demand reinvention and being
reintroduced and so he had the original
movies got the comic book he's got the
cartoon and now there's this new version
which does not replace any of those it
just extends it and maybe in the future
it gets extended more and and you know
salon as long as it's all flowing
downhill from trauma I think it'll be
See it'll be good you just teed up my
last greedy question because I only
first saw the movie but now I want more
you make a little joke about it the
movie too but if it does come to
fruition you get to make another do you
have the next chapter of Winston story
in your back pocket I have I I wouldn't
say I have like a chapter uh designed
and ready to go but I definitely like
know
the direction I would want it to go and
what I would want to happen to him in
his little family unit if if if people
were to get down and want to do another
one for sure I would have some stuff to
suggest to them